the Joe Rogan experience you've gone to
therapy yourself I have yeah did you do
that to examine this I you know I I
mainly went into it with for the
meditation port hmm to try and calm some
of my you know restlessness has writing
and all this study that you had to do to
write these books has that enhanced you
community that you have much more of an
understanding about what's at play than
the average person does well you know
again it's kind of like the patient
who's reading the emotion of reading
with the their therapists I think by
writing those books I learn a lot and it
helps me see things and that doesn't
necessarily help me lead my life any
better but it I think I understand it
better but no self no fear yeah well no
self no fear means that you have to be
you have to have this automatic
consciousness ability in order to be
afraid and that is a special human
quality the ability to put yourself in
the moment in your past and in your
future if it's not you that's gonna be
harmed by that snake then you don't have
to worry about what its gonna do to you
so if you are part of it then you worry
and it becomes you know it's an emotion
when when you're involved so I think
emotions this is a crazy idea that's in
the book that emotions didn't arise
through natural selection really well
that's the idea that they were
byproducts of other capacities that came
along first you had some kind of crude
language that enabled this hierarchical
relational reason to jump across you
know language gave you categories to
like conceptualize things hierarchical
reasoning allowed you to jump across
those categories and those kinds of
things allow you to conceptualize
yourself as an entity with an experience
so you had to have a self that could do
that kind of reasoning
and across those conceptual categories
and that is what enabled an emotion the
ability to put yourself into a
significant situation so now that it's
here now that we have once emotions are
there then they become selected but they
weren't selected by for example the
amygdala having evolved to be the fear
Center and we inherited that from
animals your animals probably have some
kinds of experiences but it's
scientifically it's very hard to know
what they have well we know like dogs
have emotions right dogs get happy well
you see their behavior right but I'm not
saying they aren't but scientifically
you can't measure that right but if you
have a dog and you come home and he's so
excited to see you and he's running
around circles that seems very emotional
a kin yeah but I don't said let's talk
about the brain for a second okay so the
parts of the brain circuits in the brain
that are involved in this kind of auto
noetic emotion that I'm talking about
this self involved in motion that's so
human such a human quality I the part of
the brain that I think is important and
this is still hypothesis it's not a fact
is something called the frontal poles
very very front part of the prefrontal
cortex that region is unique to the
human brain no other not even another
ape has that now other parts of the
prefrontal cortex are present in other
primates all of the primates but not in
any other mammal so if we can figure out
in the human brain what that frontal
pole does and what that other part that
all primates have do then that gives us
an anchor for speculating about what
other primates what kinds of experience
other primates have given what those
parts of the brain enable in us and that
would allow us to then extract what
other mammals don't have that we have
because they don't have those parts of
the brain
so it's a it's a kind of you know use of
the brain to tell us some things about
what might exist in other animals but
there's no way to ask a dog what's on
your mind
right who can measure the brain with an
fMRI or something along those lines
where you get a reading of but that's
not an answer I mean it scarlet right so
a human like I can you know if you ask
me is there a pin here on the tab I say
yes I can respond verbally or I can
point to it but when I'm responding
verbally I can only do that for
something unconscious of I can't respond
to something on unconscious of by naming
it follow them
other animals can only respond
non-verbally so they don't have that
other kind of response that is only
reflecting a conscious state so I'm not
saying they don't have anything but
scientific was very hard to know what
they have and the fact that we can study
it we know and for example fear that the
fear itself probably doesn't depend on
the amygdala but that all the behavior
that we see does makes us have to be
cautious about observing behaviors that
look like they're based on fear love and
all these other emotions when we can't
really know because we can't measure
that I mean it's a tough problem again
I'm not saying that's not there it's
just like right I guess scientifically
you know you have to you have to the
evidence yes
[Applause]